I'm here in the green room with the  selfie stick and I've got Natalie  Bennett the Green Party leader what are  you expecting from the young people in  there what are they can ask you do you  think I think this movie is topics that  are going to come up obviously  university tuition fees low pay in  secure jobs the cost of housing but I  suspect if we can sort of draw one  female for it it's going to be that  there's a real desire for change and  understanding we have to have real  change we can't continue as we are thank  you well I'll be following you with the  selfie stick hope you don't mind no  that's fine it's interesting new  technology moving on this is the first  time I have been filmed with a selfie  stick first time for everything exactly  very much the kids